voici une nouvelle iPad de 10e
génération il a deux nouvelles couleurs
ici un or très joli un design plus
moderne avec le bouton Home qui a
disparu il n'a plus de prise jack touch
ID pour le déverrouiller facilement à la
verticale et également l'horizontale un
écran un peu plus grand de 10,9 pouces
la puce à 14 bionique un bloc de charge
qui inclus et ça c'est bien et surtout
il est compatible avec l'Apple pencil de
première génération sauf que il se
recharge en usb-c et que l'Apple pencil
se recharge en Lightning apple a donc
sorti un accessoire à 10 euros qui vous
permet de venir recharger votre APPLE
pencil facilement vous branchez le SBC
dans l'iPad vous enlevez le bouchon
l'Apple pencil vous venez brancher
l'accessoire ici directement et le câble
issu de l'iPad vous êtes brancher ici
comme ça vous avez un espèce d'ensemble
extrêmement pratique on a une caméra
grand angle avec le suivi du mouvement
et on peut également venir filmer en 4K
jusqu'à 60 images par seconde on a du
wifi 6 du Bluetooth 5.2 et c'est un iPad
qui est disponible à partir de 589 euros
jusqu'à
989 € alors il pourrait vous tenter
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires